for more on the rising tensions with
North Korea and the other security
threats facing the United States were
joined from Washington by Douglas
olyphant he's a senior fellow at the net
new America and an advisor for monument
Capital Group Douglas good morning thank
you over the course of the last several
years North Korea's nuclear tests have
gotten more powerful and more dangerous
there hasn't been one this weekend as
yet but if there is one in the near
future what is your expectation well as
you point out we just have no idea what
the North Korean regime to do this is
perhaps the most opaque place on the
planet we just don't know what's going
on inside that regime so we don't know
if they didn't test this weekend
deliberately or if they didn't test this
weekend because they had a technical
problem we just don't know if there is a
test our options are somewhat limited
there there there on the peninsula they
have soul within striking power they're
extremely prickly and we just don't know
how they would respond to any military
response by the United States which is
why we've seen really nothing but
diplomacy since the end of the Korean
War North Korea says it's ready to
strike preemptively if the u.s. acts and
what it calls a recklessly aggressive
manner what do you what do you make of
that threat well again this is an
exercise in trying to figure out what's
going on inside the head of a very young
very erratic man their head of state
that we know very little about were we
to do something it is entirely possible
that they might you know go all out we
just don't know it could be that they
would give a measured response to what
we did but we just don't know what
happens if we trigger something Douglas
we don't know what will happen in the
future but we do know what's happened in
the past and the North Koreans seem to
have systematically developed this
nuclear program through the years
they've taken time between these tests
to refine these warheads do you think
there is an intercontinental ballistic
missile capable of reaching the United
States at this point I think the
consensus is that yes they have a
missile that can probably reach the
United States but they don't have the
ability to put a nuclear missile on it
or a nuclear tip on it yet so they could
in theory launch a missile that would
have conventional explode
or even chemical weapons but can't yet
strike that in a nuclear matter that's
my understanding i'm not a technical
expert on missiles but i think that's
the consensus opinion this week the u.s.
dropped the largest non-nuclear bomb
ever used in combat in afghanistan and
this comes of course on the heels of the
missile strikes in Syria how do you
think that was read in North Korea I
think the two events that you've
described the strikes in Korea and the
strike in Afghanistan are probably not
related I think each was a response to a
distinct situation but it's entirely
possible the North Koreans see this as
steps one and two and perhaps a series
of three so I suspect they're very much
on their toes and perhaps that's why we
didn't see a test this weekend Douglas
we do know though that the Obama
administration was the first to move the
quote-unquote mother of all bombs to
Afghanistan to the region so to what
degree is the Trump administration
breaking with precedent or continuing on
the same trajectory right the mother of
all bombs is a really really big bomb
but it's used for a certain tactical
situation and my understanding is that
in Nanda ha you had a situation that
lent itself to the use of this bomb you
had Isis insurgents someone were very
serious about in a tunnel system and
this bomb is uniquely designed to burn
the oxygen out of tunnels and places
like that so it was tactically
appropriate for this particular
situation and I don't think it was
necessarily seen as some unique
escalation Douglas olivan thanks for
your time thank you